Kylie Jenner talks dating in the new
life of Kylie trailer just really living
my life the 19 year old is gearing up
for the summer premiere of her own
reality series and in a new promo for
the e show kylie opens up about what she
wants her fans to know about the real
her there's two sides of me there's an
image that I feel constantly pressure to
keep up with and then there's who I
really am that's who I want you guys to
get to know Kylie hugs an unknown man
while wearing a corsage the footage is
from April when the lip kit Queen
accepted a teens invitation to prom I
hope to person I'm dating successfully
since breaking up with her on-again
off-again boyfriend Tyga in April Kylie
has been spotted on several occasions
getting cozy with rapper Travis Scott
don't go do too fresh though it's
low-key at the nice show during a stop
by watch what happens live with Andy
Cohen in May
Kylie's big sister Kim Kardashian
weighed in on her split from Tyga what
was great was that they just it was so
easy that that split they just you know
there's an has not been any drama like
it with her so what do the teens big
sisters think of Kylie's new show they
dished on Sunday season finale of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians
Kylie's just killing it I'm excited to
see her show because I literally don't
know what Kylie does all day long
yeah
[Music]